[Music]
for all of you actors out there we have
a new sponsor who can help you take your
career to the next level explains how in
this very important commercial The
Hunger Games the Wolves of Wall Street
Rove akov what do these Hollywood
blockbusters have in common me hi I'm
Jan seat I've been a silent extra with
my back to the camera in over 400
feature films and now you can - with my
new instructional video back ting like a
pro
watch how I spice up this boring scene
with techniques like where's the bus
making out with a hot guy 8 months
pregnant fun with Balu what is the scene
requires YouTube act with other factors
try my second video back ting for
couples featuring my husband Terrell
seat watch how much focus we pull with
techniques like heated argument purse
snatching describing last night's sports
games helping the blind pregnant ties to
I moved to Los Angeles to be a star but
my face is so grotesque the FCC
literally banned it from being on TV for
more than one second
now thanks to Jan see my bactine career
is going gangbusters I even booked a
part on a new cop job what a full report
DNA blood Jesus Pro and put your money
where your back is KY what the hell is
this [ __ ] you're fired
yes Oh call today
[Applause]
[Music]